Tetris it transcends age culture and
language it's a gamer and non-gamers
game but did you know Tetris has a
Soviet past Tetris is the brainchild of
this man Alexey Pajitnov
Alexey was a computer programmer in
Russia he worked for the Soviet Union at
the Moscow Academy of Sciences Alexey
always had a propensity for math
computers and puzzles it was that
propensity that led him to the creation
of the best video game of all time he
drew inspiration from a little-known
game pentominoes pentominoes was a
puzzle board game in which you had to
fit geometric shapes together Alexey
took the principles from pentominoes
upgraded them and created a computer
game originally only intended for
himself he named the game Tetris for two
reasons it's a combination of tetra the
Greek word meaning for and tennis
Pajitnov favorite sport because Tetris
was created during work hours the Soviet
Union claimed all rights to both Tetris
and all royalties boy fast forward to
1996 the rights to Tetris was finally
signed over to positon off Tetris taps
into our universal need to create order
out of chaos which is ultimately why
it's one of the most iconic games in
history
you